THIS MONTH.
MIKE.
>> ANITA, THANKS.
LET'S TALK TO BRIT HUME.
THINGS ARE SO POLARIZED, EVEN
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS
CONTROVERSIAL?
>> IT SEEMS TO BE.
THE ONE THING YOU NEVER HEAR
CRITICS OF THE COUNTRY CITE IS
SOME COUNTRY WHICH MEASURES UP
TO THEIR STANDARDS.
YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT ANOTHER
COUNTRY THAT IS DOING A BETTER
JOB.
THERE IS A REASON FOR THAT.
I CAN THINK OF NO NATION IN
HISTORY THAT TRIED HARDER OR
DONE MORE TO BRING ITS MINORITY
POPULATIONS TO THE MAINSTREAM OF
THE COUNTRY WITH ALL OF ITS
FREEDOMS AND ADVANTAGES.
IT HASN'T BEEN THAT LONG AGO
THAT SLAVERY WHICH IS TALKED
ABOUT MORE TODAY THAN ANY TIME
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR, WAS
EVERYWHERE.
GOING BACK TO BIBLICAL TIMINGS.
-- TIMES.
IT WAS EVERYWHERE.
THIS COUNTRY HAS GONE A LONG WAY
TO REMEDY THE ILLS THAT GREW OUT
OF THAT:
LACK OF FREEDOM AND VIOLATION OF
HUMAN RIGHTS.
YOU NEVER HEAR THE CRITICS SAY
WE WOULD LIKE TO BE LIKE THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY CAN'T.
>> THIS COMES AFTER HE HAD
A 2-TERM AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PRESIDENT AND NOW AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FEMALE
VICE-PRESIDENT.
>> THAT'S ONE MORE SIGN OF HOW
OPEN THIS COUNTRY HAS BECOME AND
MUCH MORE OPPORTUNITY IS
AVAILABLE NOW TO MINORITY
POPULATIONS THAN EVER USED TO BE
THE CASE.
IT AND MAYBE ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD.
THE PEOPLE WHO SAY THESE THINGS
THAT DO A WONDERFUL JOB OF
GETTING PUBLICITY FOR
THEMSELVES.
THE SQUAD GETS COVERAGE FAR
BEYOND ITS INFLUENCE.
YOU WONDER IF THEY HAVE ANY
HISTORICAL KNOWLEDGE AND
REMEMBER THE CIVIL WAR AND THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND ITS
GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS.
AMONG THEIR GREATEST ACHIEVEMENT
WAS THE CONSENSUS IN THIS
COUNTRY AGAINST RACISM.
BEING LABELED A RACIST IS ONE OF
THE WORST THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN
TO YOU.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SIMPLY DO
NOT APPROVE OF RACISM.
THEY ARE AGAINST IT.
THAT'S NOT TRUE IN EVERY OTHER
COUNTRY BUT IT'S TRUE HERE.
YOU WOULD THINK THESE PEOPLE
WERE BORN 10 YEARS AGO.
DO THEY NOT KNOW WHAT IT WAS
LIKE WHEN HE DID HAVE SYSTEMIC
RACISM UNTIL THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT WHEN LAWS WERE STACKED
AGAINST BLACK PEOPLE?
ALL OF THAT HAS BEEN WIPED AWAY.
>> AS A MAN OF FAITH IT MAKES
YOU WONDER WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO
HEAL THIS GREAT COUNTRY WITH
THOSE FOLKS.
>> IT WILL TAKE A CONSIDERABLE
LEADER.
I AM NOT SURE WE HAVE ONE YET.